we might be drunk we
might be drunk as long as we
are hanging out you know we might be
drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] head peeps
wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk we might be drunk
yeah here we are
folks we might be drunk it's uh midday
on a wednesday it's raining out in new
york city
and what are we drinking here sammy baby
bloody mary's
is it's the ultimate day drink you got
that right
it's pretty nice good hangover cure i
feel like draper you know he had a rough
night with some hula and then uh
he goes home and has one of these at the
office you just combined the two best
dramas ever maybe
draper and hua was that uh she was a
[ __ ]
sopranos oh yeah yeah yeah i was
thinking you were i thought you were
talking about a pacino
oh no what was that called son of a
woman son of a woman
that was that movie we've talked about
in this podcast before it's one of those
like
horrible movies that every thanksgiving
if it's on tv i just watched
can't not watch it it's it's very
watchable yes
but it's like dude a blind guy driving a
car and it's supposed to be like a
feel-good moment you're like
this is how people die i know i usually
killed a kid
yeah yeah chris o'donnell he was so cute
he was a cute kid
90s very 90s very watchable kind of
fun drama with heart heart but it was a
real i owe you oscar
yes yes exactly we burned you on
godfather
dog day afternoon all these classics and
all like just [ __ ] take it
it's like departed that was like one of
scorsese's weirdest movies and that's
the only good movie
that's good but it's no raging bull it's
no good fellas it's no
uh even cape fear i love
yeah great comedy
hours love after hours but then departed
what are you gonna do
chop me up and feed me to the poor yeah
yeah you white lace
curtain [ __ ] i like that every cop in
that movie is just quoting joyce
yeah i know every boston cop reads james
joyce
yeah and everybody's got a tude you know
alec baldwin's like god dammit get over
here and he hits the guy with the file
you know
that was a great scene that was a great
seat he's got the the tit sweat
going so funny who the [ __ ] are you i'm
the guy who does his job you must be the
other guy
yeah they're just fist fighting in the
back seat like what are we doing here
it's fun though it is fun don't i saw it
in the theater twice don't get me wrong
it's a fun ass
it's also ridiculous it's just saying
the n word in that intro for no reason
like there's no reason to open this
movie with this many n-bombs right
you're a black guy in boston you don't
need my help to get [ __ ]
anthony anderson's in that for like
eight minutes he's grading it yeah yeah
based on a japanese film yeah infernal
affairs
is that it yeah not internal it's
infernal
can we double check that check it out we
got a new screen coming up
yeah i think he nailed it infernal there
you go
yeah what does infernal mean i have no
idea all right i just remember the name
huh like remember they did uh the movie
vanilla sky with tom cruise
and that was supposed to be great that
was also penelope cruz she was in both
of them
imagine being like that is she gets [ __ ]
on a lot but like you're in the spanish
and english version of the movie that's
impressive that's pretty crazy yeah it's
like when uh
tom segura does spanish stand up you're
like jesus who is this like a gifted
child
that's crazy very impressive carmen
lynch same thing yeah that's right
you know um yeah it's funny we were just
talking about sal accused our boy
he gets a mention on almost every
podcast our buddy salaccus but uh
he's saying how our podcast we start we
start with a
high we hit we hit a wall because we get
drunk and in the second half we kind of
slow down yeah and he's like you need
something he goes like
you know homeless pimp who does chris
destefano's podcast like of course we
know him
he goes he's got great ideas like he's
like producing it he's got great ideas
one of his ideas
is uh chrissy edibles like chris takes
edibles
oh yeah you think we couldn't come up
with doing drugs i know we could just do
a bump on the back half how about that
sally
it's noon you think we couldn't crack
that we're already doing a drug
yeah good point but it's not enough i
need heroin
like that'll keep us high that'll keep
us up we're just
both like drooling on minute 51 yeah
boy this this just the taste you know a
smell can bring you back
yeah the taste of this reminds me of
like being in the park in new orleans
like
19 years old chugging these just to try
to kill the hangover
yeah killing a hangover is a young man's
game though you get a little older and
you kind of just got to take it
take it you deserve the punishment and
you got to ride it out because if you
just keep getting back on that horse
it'll never end
yeah you keep killing the hang of i mean
that's that's like all the great right i
think like all the great writers of
their day were just alcoholics
how the [ __ ] did they do it well i don't
think they knew the uh
the health risk that they were actually
doing i think they were just like hey i
feel good now
you know like they all had elixirs this
is my snake oil this is my tonic
you gotta know the hell like just how a
hangover makes you feel you gotta be
like this can't be good can't be good
yeah my body is telling me something
but you know you see those old guinness
ads it's like makes you strong
get you laid it helps you fight and all
this [ __ ] and you're like
maybe i do need one makes you think
you're strong yeah yeah
but yeah these writers man you know what
it was they needed to create obstacles
because
they didn't have like they didn't have
like hemingway and bukowski all these
alcoholic writers they didn't have the
distraction of the internet
i know they were distracted like oh look
at all these cats that look like tommy
lee jones on
buzzfeed they didn't have to deal with
that [ __ ] right that's so true they just
stared at the sea
yeah that was all they needed or a
beautiful woman or whatever the sunset
that's what it was it was women because
they all these guys were either divorced
or sex
addicts totally was divorced like four
times that
bukowski had a book women where
literally just flying women out
to his place and it's like by the way
that's you think like dating
apps are [ __ ] sketchy yeah he'd look
at one picture and be like
i'm buying a plane ticket well the guy
looked like a [ __ ] gargoyle i mean
he's one of the ugliest men
in history he was very ugly and he had a
thing for ugly chicks i think
yeah he was like all over like fat
chicks and all this stuff
so he was probably like the first ugly
guy to make it
and get laid god there's got to be
people before i mean i like true [ __ ]
napoleon yeah good point good point by
the way napoleon
italian guy yeah i didn't know that i
always thought he was french
oh no you the the the wise guys love him
is that right yeah
oh yeah that makes sense didn't tony
have a picture of him on his
uh and then and then uh paulie changed
it to
tony yeah yeah that was great and tony
sees it like what the [ __ ]
yeah yeah he's my favorite character
hands down paulie walnuts yeah paulie
wong
it's not that we might be drunk if we
don't mention solo queues and sopranos
every episode that's true
good boy no he's he's the best he's so
funny he loves his mother i love when he
when he punches out chrissy for making
fun of him he calls his mom a [ __ ] so
he punches him and during the
intervention i mean come on
the intervention is the best chris is
probably my favorite but
oh i like chris too chrissy they were
the best when he sits on
little cosette brutal [ __ ] you can't
tony can murder any human but you you
[ __ ] with an animal you're
dead to him that's like a great sign of
a sociopath that's right
that's true uh serial killers still like
worry about animals they'll bludgeon a
woman with a
with a pipe but uh don't hurt a cat
so weird yeah i don't like animal stuff
either even when i see like a little kid
playing with a cat too rough i'm like
ah what are you doing yeah when people
like you ever see someone who's like
rough with their dog and you're just
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with you i
know
i know i mean we've talked about it
before with the blowing weed smoke in
the dog's face or putting beer in the
bowl you're like come on
yeah i don't like it yeah give the guy a
break
what uh what else is going on man oh
well i i we were talking about scent of
a woman i wanted to veer off to this
uh what do you think about stevie wonder
some people have a conspiracy theory
that he's not blind what
yeah well there's some video matt
or harry if you pull it up there's a
video of somebody like throwing him a
microphone and he catches it
have you heard about this or am i just
drunk at night on youtube uh in my
pajamas with half a boner
is this it uh-huh here we go is stevie
wonder blind then how do you grab the
mic
maybe he's like daredevil blind oh
there's paul mccartney we're doing some
kind of a
big hey look it fell there oh he grabbed
it
let me see watch this he drops the
microphone
and he caught it maybe he felt it maybe
he felt it i'm sure he's blind all right
everybody's got a theory about
everything there's all these conspiracy
theory
podcasts i think we ours was debunked in
12 seconds
i think that lasted not even 30 seconds
pretty impressive though
he still caught that microphone they say
your other senses are raised if you're
blind i mean like if you see blind
people
uh on the street they're pretty good
with the stick usually they do know
where they're
i mean you know a blind guy walk around
new york
that's like a kid in the vatican it's
just high risk
what are you crazy i don't his name
escapes me right now he's a really funny
guy
does drug special shane something blonde
shane moss
yes he's a joke who goes if you got the
right pair of sunglasses you can take a
cni dog just about anywhere
oh no a dog just about anywhere see i
[ __ ] up the gym it's funny
you take a dog just about anywhere
that's a great great observation
yeah speaking of the seeing eye dog and
this sounds like a bit but i think it's
just a fun idea yeah
if you're a like a worker dog seeing eye
anxiety dog
cop dog whatever it is bomb squad dog
yeah
you gotta want to be drug dog the most
first of all you're at the airport
you're kind of hanging out you can sniff
coke i'm sure you get a little bump
every now and then or you're in like
bolivia
i don't know it seems like seeing eye
dog i'm like taking this [ __ ] to the
park
sorry i'm taking this uh handy to the
park and uh you know
whatever you know okay maybe we'll walk
around a little bit
i gotta pull this guy through traffic
but the sea the drug dog
is like living they they command the
most respect too
yes they're they're like they're like
leading uh
they're leading the cop around right
they're being around they're like
follow me i gotta lead that's a great
point and you go yeah of course
go baby you got it that's a good that's
a great observation yeah the cni dog
is definitely you're basically a nanny
you're a nanny you're babysitting you're
like
the [ __ ] for the you're helping the guy
all right come on let's go
let's go you're about to get hit by a
car but the drug dog is living
who picks up after the cni dog oh
that's a great question i love it write
that down
really god there's no way that's not
been done i think it might have been
done but that's a funny angle
yeah who's picking up that yeah see it's
been done
ah okay yeah damn it's like a meme
all right damn it's a great question
though it is a good question
yeah also the blind guy's gotta wipe his
ass
yeah and you gotta help like how does
that work what the blind guy asked why
that's a robert schimmel joke oh it's
how to blind people know know when
they're done wiping their ass
yeah exactly but i think the seeing eye
dog has to assist
with the uh the ass wiping i assume
yeah i don't know about that do you
really think with their paw
what do you think they're doing well
they got a lot of fur
that's when i know i'm getting too drunk
is when i'm using my pets as a napkin
my cat walks by and i'm like hang on i
got some ketchup on my hand there
you got barbecue sauce in your jeans and
your puppy's head yes
terrible yeah i use jeans as a nap man
same same they should make napkins out
of denim just because they're close
by the way thank you i got these at the
gap on the road on sale because i was
out of pants
i like you don't see i don't see cargo
pants that fit a lot
they're always they always seem too
baggy those look like they fit they fit
like a glove they're tapered at the
bottom and i put my merch money in the
cargos
yeah so when i put my my [ __ ] through
the security at the airport
no one thinks about i got wads and wads
of hundreds in here
and it just goes right through it's a
shady look for the airport though
it is it does make you look like you
have a dime bag in one of those pockets
you know no doubt about it and if they
pulled it out they'd be like what's all
this cash about
and i'm like i sell shirts that say
comedy on them
that's uh i swear to god that's a thing
it's uh
yeah you don't see cargo shorts that
that fit that's like it's a big
uh that's a big victory i heard a woman
once say because cargo shorts are out
are they yeah who know who can keep up
with fashion
but like i all these women were like hey
man we wear cargo shorts you're a dork
whatever
and one woman wrote all these guys were
like i didn't know that sorry and one
woman wrote
uh just wear the [ __ ] shorts if you
want to wear them
that's the hottest thing exactly to me
that's like fashion it's just like
not i mean and i don't know it so but to
me it's like just do what you want to do
yes and confidence kind of comes through
i think guys when you when you really
remember an outfit
they're [ __ ] up oh if it's like a
little too loud
it's kind of like like if you remember
an outfit it means the dude wore
a shirtless george costanza shirt right
right posing the art of seduction
yeah they're like oh [ __ ] i remember
that ain't good
a black t-shirt and like a jean jacket
no one no one [ __ ]
exactly you want a hint of view like i
think a shoe
or a shirt can really pop in in a good
way but yeah you don't want
you don't want to be memorable you don't
want to stand out any time a guy goes
can i pull this off
you probably can't exactly that's it a
hint of you that might be a we might be
drunk cologne
oh we come out cologne is kind of
douchey to me cologne's a problem
you know i'm so i'm at no no offense
vinnie brand i was just at uh
bridgeport stress factory and vinnie is
going on he's like i need i'm gonna get
you your first cologne i was like
i'm gonna throw it in the [ __ ]
garbage if you get me a cologne he goes
smell this tell me you don't notice how
good this smells i was like i'm not
gonna smell you
i don't want to smell you and if i can
smell you like
even if it's subtle i'd rather i think
women also
prefer a natural scent we've talked
about we prefer a natural scent on women
yeah and just the idea of going i can't
live with myself doing that
it feels like a douchebag it feels like
was there a time when cologne was more
acceptable i feel like i think so
i think it was well aftershave i can do
because you know it's very matte you
know you shave and you do it my dad used
to do that
and you know his teeth would smell like
a dad like it's like english leather or
whatever the hell it was after shave is
kind of manly
it's kind of manly yeah it hurts exactly
men have to feel pain yeah so i felt
like that a little bit like men when
they hug they hit
because we still have to be hurting each
other that's a great point
that is true yeah you know i remember
even when axe body spray first came out
like
i was using that as a substitute for
roll-on deodorant which you can't do
no no i didn't realize i went to a
basketball camp in philly and i was like
the only white kid at the camp
yeah and they were all like what the
[ __ ] like you need real deodorant
that was like it became a thing to [ __ ]
on me yeah for using axe body spray
i was just i was just i'm lazy i just
grabbed it and ran out you know and just
shh yeah yeah
but when you're sweating all week at a
basketball camp holy [ __ ] it has no
antiperspirant it just smells good i
think i don't like annie purse sprint
though
i like powder i use women's deodorant
i'm saying it right here
yeah i use the secrets
yeah there's more give i also shave my
legs but we'll get to that later
i'm going to bend over you're going to
bend over to tie your shoes is that a
thong
mark's wearing what the hell it's riding
up the whale tail
yeah no i i use women's deodorant
because i like the powder i don't like
the jelly
gooey uh liquid [ __ ] yeah i hate i hate
remember when it would be like it would
look like play-doh you would you would
do the little
twist on deodorant like play-doh and
you're like oh yeah you think i want
like moisture
exactly i'm wet enough jelly's gross i
don't mind the roll-on though and it
just kind of like i like a roll-on i
like a roll-on
is good i just i like to sweat i think
sweating is natural i don't want to not
sweat
i guess but i hate when i'm at the uh
you know at the dmv and just feel that
boop that drip i hate that drip it's
like an iv
for uh you know like well a hungover
sweat
there's nothing quite like it no or a
bomb sweat which i know is not relatable
but
joel is one time bombed so hard on an
outdoor corporate gig and he's wearing a
suit
and he took his blazer off and he had
like a dress shirt on and the whole back
was wet
and it was a great photo he just showed
the photo wow
it was perfect damn back sweat i get
that i get that so bad on a bomb
yeah yeah it's weird when you start to
like i remember uh
there's a bill hicks special where he's
just sweating his ass off yeah i think
it's his half hour
his one night stand which is a great
special hbo but uh
his sweat was [ __ ] crazy oh you
pointed you got a picture
yes yeah black people were smart enough
to just bring the towel
whitey never really did it it looks
weird when you're dead well i mean
bernie mac sweating back yeah
certain comics i think martin lawrence
was a sweater oh he always went into a
coma from sweating do you remember what
i think
didn't martin lawrence go into a coma
from i think he was jogging
and he he wanted to lose weight so he
was wearing a sweatshirt while he jogged
wow i mean martin lawrence to be fair
though would wear a full leather suit
with no shirt under it so he's basically
like cutting weight to get on the
wrestling team
during his set that is true it's like
doing kegels you know
i'm doing them now to lose weight an
upcoming movie had to put on several
layers of clothing to sweat off the
pounds he subsequently suffered heat
stroke
when he arrived at the uh medical center
in thousand oaks california
lawrence clocked in with a 107 degree
body temperature holy [ __ ]
man damn was this before or after the
nervous breakdown on the highway with
the
with the handgun i don't know man martin
lawrence was a great comic actor though
his show was great so good i loved
martin i even liked the movies that
weren't like even like blue streak it's
like it's got chappelle in it it's
i still love blue streaks yeah yeah
and we've all heard the chris rock story
where he blew him off stage
really you never heard this oh man chris
rock was on snl so he's like blowing up
a little bit you know and he's a good
stand-up
but he's like us he's like a joke guy
sure he's got a little more energy and
he paces but
he should just stand there and tell
jokes he's at cleveland improv or
somewhere
martin lawrence unheard of no name you
know opener guy
kills kills and he was like
i can't follow that and he bombed so
after that he started prowling the stage
and everything because he
knew he couldn't just stand and deliver
he had to do the energy thing so that
[ __ ] his whole world up [ __ ] yeah
martin lawrence man just an unknown
murderer
yeah i remember you so crazy i used to
watch that dvd all the time as a kid
mm-hmm what was the one with the
cleavage on the cover
it was like the hottest cover matt pull
it up it was uh after dark or talking
dirty after dark
as a kid that was pretty hot uh for me
it's just it just tits
on a box cleavage shot it's a special
oh god now we're gonna get to come up
here too i think they do that in post oh
okay
yeah come on come on
i remember a thin line between love and
hate uh the woman in that movie was so
hot do you remember that movie
no i don't know if i caught that that
was uh that was a martin lawrence
i loved martin lawrence man yeah i did
too
i think he's is he still going yeah he
just did the new bad boys movie
oh great with will smith that actually
did good numbers i think
i think that was like the last movie to
do good numbers before the pandemic
oh wow damn but uh yeah man it was like
yeah there we go lynn whitfield i think
she's hot right
she's really pretty holy [ __ ] no it was
a comedy special i swear to god i think
it was hbo
after dark talking dirty damn it it was
just
the whole box was just two boobs oh man
now i feel like i'm crazy
i'm losing it well we'll find we can't
just stare at a screen but yeah
yeah martin lawrence underrated what a
beast
damn i had something about uh the purse
oh yeah
i go powder i went i tried it one day on
the road that's all they had and i
needed deodorant
and uh i never went back big fan powder
secret strong enough for a man if you go
women's powder
i do women's powder jesus oh yeah
secret i used to have a joke about how
like you know if you if you get a
you know men doing little things like uh
you know like if you get a sex change
people say you're a hero if you
transition well you're very brave
but if i get like my eyebrows tweets
they're like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you do the little things you get called
out for it but you go all in
so true the little things i think about
that and you're like yeah i could see
latest deal i mean i've used
girlfriend's deodorant before yeah
because you just you're like what's
there and i don't have it
right right that's a good point i think
it's the same for women like if a woman
you know transitions that's great but if
a woman's like eating a chili dog
and wearing boxers nah that's still kind
of hot
women like women like an oversized shirt
they love an oversized shirt women like
to feel small
yes which is not what men want we're the
opposite i always wonder like smaller
guys who date taller women like you
think like
you think nicole kidman ever threw one
of tom cruise's shirts on like
yeah this doesn't really fit
yeah he's gotta be what five seven five
seven wow did you hear that story that
just came out about tom cruise
and uh how he saved elizabeth shu's life
from it was like a helicopter blade
harry you probably pulled this up
tom cruise helicopter elizabeth shoe uh
yeah it's like a reverse jonathan landis
whatever happened here he saved her
wow he's a real live faction star he
saved her from
yeah spinning blades while on set part
of me is like
can you do you need the real blades i
know right you fake guns
yeah he's an odd duck that cruise you
hear all these stories how he's like the
greatest guy and like
i remember bill hader told a story about
how he uh
he like he heard someone in his family
was dying or very ill and he made sure
the
set was like boom boom boom to get him
out of there oh wow so you hear all
these great things
i just think scientology's got to be
rough yeah it seems like they got a grip
on you and they don't let go
they squeeze you to death because they
know all your secrets deodorant
but yeah he's uh he's an odd duck he
apparently jimmy kimmel has that story
about how he showed up at his super bowl
with his mom and cupcakes
and he's like oh hey you know we're all
drinking beers watching football and you
show up with your mom and then
he's one of these guys who just does
push-ups randomly really because he's
like ah we're wasting time i can be
productive i can do push-ups
that is [ __ ] hilarious i know that's
like a thing you see a character doing a
movie and you're like shut up
exactly that's like rory gold on
entourage yeah he's comedy gold but he's
not trying to be funny
you know he's on oprah's couch you know
going nuts that was [ __ ] brutal
brutal brutal but you know i do love tom
cruise though i do too does his own
stunts and he boy he looks amazing for
his age he looks amazing he looks
amazing for our age
for his age he's got [ __ ] abs yeah
660.
by the way vanilla sky he's in that is
that a good movie or not like it
feels like it's a departedy it's on the
line i can't know what it is
it kind of is and it kind of it's like
it's weird and it's interesting
and i don't know if it's quite good i
feel the same way it's like
it doesn't all the way make sense i
don't think i i i it's almost like when
you
have like a drug fueled dream or
something and it's just like
all right it's like a dream sequence
episode of a show where you're like yeah
did did this just waste my time or was
it kind of riveting i can't tell
can't tell i know i'm with you he's
grading it
he's great the the ladies are super hot
and it's a great idea and it's cameron
crowe
who does great work right great or
horrible great or horrible
so it's like you can't that was one we
were like i don't know i don't know but
i saw the theater i remember leaving
being like
that was good right and my date was like
yeah i think so it was
it was cool to see in the theater
because it was like so you know big the
movie was so big but yeah i mean
tom cruise so many my favorite role of
his ever was magnolia
he got robbed at the oscar that year man
unbelievable movie
is that that's a pta yeah unbelievable
movie that movie's incredible i haven't
seen it forever
i wonder if it holds up oh i saw it like
a year ago and i loved it again it was
uh c riley is great he's he like steals
the show in that moment
is great yeah and the intertwining
stories i love that
william h macy oh my god william h macy
one of the most underrated character
yeah i mean i think fargo is in my top
five movies ever
wow yeah no i can't can't argue with
that
can't go wrong with cohen see they've
had some [ __ ] too which ones are [ __ ]
well we talked about this before i don't
love the the uh clooney one
oh intolerable cruelty i don't love it
it's like a throwback hollywood
screwball comedy i think it's pretty
good
i think it's like it's a different movie
and i'm like i love clooney man
i think he's i think he's great so i i
think he's pretty funny in it and
catherine jada jones is so [ __ ] hot
in it
yeah yeah i still can't get over her uh
laser beam scene and entrapment yes
don't pull that up matt because it'll
get us all excited yeah we don't get we
don't need a [ __ ] picture tent in
here
yeah in the mid 90s it didn't get any
hotter than that but
going below a laser sean connery man
[ __ ] a toast to [ __ ] sean connery
oh yes cause we lost him and he's a bad
[ __ ] i'll tell you one of my
favorite movies ever
the man who would be king i think it's
based on
uh woody kipling uh i don't know that
one yeah dude amanda would be king it's
sean connery
michael kane is incredible oh yeah and i
think christopher plummer
uh one of the best movies ever wow
it's [ __ ] phenomenal it's quite a
review yeah it's like
these guys who basically i haven't seen
in years but it's incredible
these guys who basically overtake a
village and they trick them into
thinking they're gods and
things go pretty [ __ ] bad but it's
really really good okay oh
i gotta check that out yeah what's harry
look up it's woodyard kipling amanda
will be king it's a different name the
the book i don't know what it's called
sean connery
famous for bar fights really oh yeah
scottish guys are the toughest guys it's
they're not the name i don't know it's
it's i don't know why but it's a
different name for sure but
um whatever kipling i'm pretty sure i
could be [ __ ] totally wrong here
yeah i'm still worried about the uh the
martin lawrence special
i'm telling you that we're all over this
[ __ ] because yeah
we we go from do we go from lawrence to
connery we'll go anywhere man
oh yeah i love i got another toast to me
oh i'll put it please i don't know if
i've done this because
you know we drank on this every week but
uh which could be a start to any
sentence we ever say on this
but a toast to uh you ever go to your
local sandwich shop
and my guy will go he'll go the regular
and i said yeah and he just makes a
sandwich oh you've mentioned this before
that i love it that's the best the usual
so this is a toast into a peeve
all right oh he said the regular today
and he gave me american cheese instead
of cheddar oh
that stinks that hurts i got an issue
american cheese is fine but here's my
issue with it it sticks to the top of
your [ __ ] mouth
it's the captain crunch of cheese
there's issues
it affects the top of your mouth it's
definitely the most chemically
fakey process that's why it's american
you know it's got all the [ __ ] in it
but yeah the favorite tits of cheese
it's the fake tits of cheese
it works and i actually like eating it
plain i'll just like the way homer
simpson would just eat craft singles
yeah i'll [ __ ] do that all day i'm
with you but i like
i like cheddar on my eggs man oh i love
it that's my go-to
i'm with you what's energy cheddar and
american is there a big difference
because they're the same goddamn color
i i don't know but i'm going by the
taste here harry what
can we pull that up the difference
between cheddar and american i've always
wondered that
i like cheddar better yeah i think i do
too but they kind of work on a lot of
this
like you could do turkey cheddar turkey
american you kind of do either
yeah you know what feels good to order i
feel like i know some [ __ ] was when i
ordered pepper jack
give me the pepper jack pepper jack is
good [ __ ] that's good [ __ ]
i like a provolone i like swiss i'm a
big cheese queef
i love cheese i'll [ __ ] with some
jalapeno cheddar you ever do that
habanero cheddar oh that's good that's
the good [ __ ]
you gotta be careful because you're
gonna pay for that later that's true you
can't start the day with a bloody mary
and a habanero cheddar i'll tell you
that right it's gonna be [ __ ] and fire
yeah that's so true cheese man that's
why cheese is an upcharge
it's like that old chris rock joke damn
she had to get some cheese on her
whopper
[Laughter]
cheddar's a hard english cheese while
american is smooth and creamy processed
yes
processed rice big tits of cheese
cheddar's big tits but they're natural
yeah
big natties
cheddar and you know what's weird is
when it's sharp i love a sharp
cheddar it's just the best we i don't
like white american or white cheddar
easy
that's the great like uh the ethnic
comic move where you're just like
why's it gotta be white cheddar you're
just like i i feel like this doesn't
have anything to do with the writers
white chocolate sucks am i right it's
all about real chocolate dark chocolate
i do like dark chocolate better though i
like milk
uh yeah you get aged cheddar there's no
aged american
yeah exactly yeah we get rid of our old
people we don't respect them
cuomo talking to you nursing home
yeah you're right that's fascinating
interesting
very american of us very processed and
there's no aged
craft singles there's something sad
about american being the single one
yeah you can't find anybody so true it's
gonna be on its own
and much like people in america if they
have flaws like you throw out a
terrorcraft single it's worthless it's
gotta be the full square
damn that's a good point you know what i
do love though i was gonna trash
packaged cheese but
i'm string cheese till i die dude i like
string cheese too it's just peeling it
apart
it feels fun it's a project yeah it's
fun
yeah you do a thing while you eat it i
like it brings you back to childhood
something about this pandemic brought me
back to childhood nostalgia
yeah yeah and it's like yeah there's
something about
having like a sugary cereal or oh i love
a sugary cereal or
you know string cheese man yeah i'm a
sucker for some chocolate milk
yes i love a good choco milk oh
dude there was there was a run for
chocolate milk where they were like you
can have it after a workout it's got a
lot
got a lot of protein in it that's right
apparently first of all i think it was
invented in jamaica fun fact really give
it a goog
and uh it's apparently it gives you more
energy than an energy drink
with the sugar it's all sugar yeah yeah
and i guess the milk has some protein i
don't know but yeah i love it you give
me a yoo-hoo
and i'll blow you i love you you who
sounds like what you say to someone
before you blow them yeah
you you
yeah that's one hell of a crazy straw
you got there
but uh yeah i love i do love you who i
love i mean
ned's quick might be my favorite that's
my go-to man this is where i'm gonna
lose you though
i don't like strawberry milk it's it's
great for the first sip yeah and then
you lose me they even do banana milk now
and i'm like
slow down oh god that's like that's like
that's like the femdum
yes that's like you know then put me in
a leather suit and beat me over the
chocolate milk people and like
i want the classic just [ __ ] missionary
yeah i'm good yeah yeah don't peg me
with your banana milk
i like vanilla chocolate milk though
vanilla milk
vanilla milk yeah they do like that
feels like an oxymoron there's too many
whites
vanilla and milk i don't know it feels
like uh overlap but
i'll try it they call the departed
i'll tell you i'll do some eggnog egg
you [ __ ] love it i love eggnog i'll
drink eggnog in the summer
yeah i like it i like nutmeg and
cinnamon and anything
oh yeah can't go wrong with cinnamon
back to cheese though
the swiss cheese guy whoever invented
swiss cheese is a genius because he's
saving like 30
of his his income just uh putting holes
in that [ __ ] he's doing what the donut
and the bagel people did
yes but he took it over to cheese and
there's even more holes there's way more
holes in this story
and what he should do is keep those
holes and sell that
swiss holes it also became used as an
insult
a-hole no like like if you're playing if
you're playing bad defense he's playing
swiss cheese defense
this story's got a lot of holes in it
holes are negative
yeah that's true it works that's true
yeah it still works
because it differentiates yeah from uh
from you know the cheddars and the
provolones because it's got holes in it
it's holes hole swiss hole by the way
sounds like an [ __ ] from switzerland
i also don't like whole i mean glory
hole
that's not it's that's not a good hole
either that's not great but they are
socially distant
yeah you're getting the uh you're
cutting off the breath
all right but yeah no you're right hey
hey we might be drunk folks
is brought to you by honey
oh yeah you know we all uh
especially with this pandemic we all
shop online we all look for coupons
we're all looking for a hot deal
that's the genius of honey honey
you don't have to search anymore for a
promo code or anything honey is free
browser extension that
scours the internet for discount codes
when you're ready to check out honey
automatically applies the best one
is instant savings that is a genius idea
you got to get on honey you got to do it
today so you can save some cash
honey has found its customers over 2
billion bucks
in savings supported by over 30 000
stores online
buy anything from tech and gaming
products to beer and wine
you got to get on it i buy shoes all the
time online i buy uh like toilet paper
and toothpaste why the hell not you know
i don't want to go to the store
and i could use honey to get all these
deals and steals it's it's so nice i i
used to i was the
guy that would always type in promo code
for this thing
that honey does this automatically it is
pretty damn cool yeah
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings it's literally free
yeah it installs in just a few seconds
save some dough and support this podcast
get honey for free at joinhoney.com
drunk
that's join honey.com drunk
and get that honey baby yeah buy some
cheese
have it delivered and get a deal i do
like swiss cheese a lot
i do too i love that might be my
favorite cheese really yeah it gets hit
on
it does it's cause of the holes i guess
no i think it's cause it's got like some
people think it's got a weird flavor
oh maybe that's what i like about it
it's a mature flavor yeah
by the way the first guy to eat cheese
was pretty optimistic
it's old milk yeah and he was like i'll
eat it [ __ ] it
i bet i bet they didn't get it all the
way right first time he just had some
like in between [ __ ] it was pretty damn
bad totally totally but it kind of
it's a it's a symbol for you can still
work with something even if it's
shitty you know because it's rotten milk
that's been out for too long and yet
it's
hugely popular raisins raisins another
great example optimism you never know
even the first guy to eat a lemon was
probably like whoo i could use this
yes you know because that's just a hint
just a hint exactly
so things can be spun to a positive all
these negative cuts out there would just
turn everything down
these no men get out of here we wouldn't
have these great things if you
if you were around you negative nancy
yeah
no no man negative nancy you got both
you got both groups there you know i
think something about swiss cheese is so
adult like i feel like
if you don't like swiss cheese you
probably don't go down on women
ah yeah you're probably like yeah i
don't know grow up
grow up they're both delicious and they
both take a man's palate
get some sufficient or a woman you know
something i'm in later too don't want to
exclude anybody
sure swiss cheese and vagina both are
the adult
uh i'm going too far here guys no i like
it i like it
yeah no you're right this whole like
some people like cheese whiz and all
this like come on get out of here well
cheese whiz is like it's like the
american cheese people the cheese whiz
are like the philly cheesesteak people
yeah they want the cheese but i'm i'm a
provolone guy for my cheesesteak
i don't go ways that's a superior cheese
for sure
i'll do whatever because i don't get
beat up by a psycho guy in philly but
there's all these camps i i'm so sick of
these cat i'm a prolonged
i'm a whiz guy you got to go to mikeys i
go to pete's like all right
life's too short we're going to have
gino's path yeah yeah
you went to paso gino those are the
commercial ones i'm here for two days
get off my case i know and also it
tastes the exact same i'm gonna [ __ ]
blood after
let me get on with my life look at
diarrhea isn't that all we really need
to do here
i'm torturing myself eating this foot
long of shitty meat and horrible cheese
and peppers and i have to do two shows
tonight i'm i can't move
exactly yeah same that goes for you deep
dish queefs out there i got a knife and
fork out and a bib on like what am i
doing i look like i ate out a chick on
her berry and i'm covered in red sauce
it's too much the deep dish pizza is so
aggressive
it's a lot it's got a lot of confidence
because like it really started like the
anti-carb movement
to go even harder bigger like [ __ ] you
that's what happened a lot of these
places had health food movements
and then the unhealthy places went even
further like you know in atlanta
laughing skull place
they have like meals like the heart
attack
it's a burger with two grilled cheese
sandwiches for buns
hard-boiled eggs bacon slathered in
butter and you're like look
do i want to die tonight i know i know
also
do these shows play in third world
countries can you
see that like i've been eating uh grass
for like six months and you're showing
me a hard-boiled egg on top of steak
on top of bacon on top of a pancake i
mean what are we doing to these people
that's crazy that's uh what do you call
it um shaming
it's so aggressive it's funny it's
really a reaction to be like [ __ ] you we
don't get potentially like how about the
people that have to work at these places
i know and then they're like i don't
have time to go to get a meal i guess
i'll have the uh
fried egg burger grilled cheese again
yeah exactly this guy's 600 pounds he's
just
he needs some energy to serve people
yeah yeah you got to learn cpr when you
go there just
because it's it's part of it i get the
cpap machine and the
defibrillator out johnny's on his sixth
uh
heart attack they do tater tot nachos ah
those are good though they're [ __ ]
amazing they're good you can have four
of them because it's a [ __ ] tater tot
but yeah i love it it's so good i don't
feel like nachos and this were all loot
to sell volcanoes pot i'm a little
worried yeah but we're kind of yes andy
they're versus each other good points
out versus each other we're kind of just
every once in a while we're going to
talk food we talk movies a ton
yeah it's true he did sean o'connor uh
sean o'connor sean connery then we did
uh
martin lawrence yeah we're all over the
place here folks it's called stream of
consciousness but
uh nachos i feel like haven't been
perfected
wow well i didn't know this side of you
well as a as a bit of an ocd
and a bit of a an analytical [ __ ] guzzler
i think i don't like the pile on the top
then you got these
random tortillas that are naked on the
side
i want it all to be that's why i like
soup and chili and
gumbo and cream based or whatever
chowder
it's all on board you're a real soup
you're a real soup queef mark
i am i'm a soup nazi because i i don't
like the idea of this nacho
getting half of what this one is who's
completely buried in the goods
what are you communist cuba you know
it's interesting you know
uh you make an interesting point because
during the pandemic places because the
nachos for shared food some restaurants
would do like
single nachos so you could still share
them but it would be like dressed every
trip
ah now that i'm on board i went with
with salakis and i went to a mexican
place in his hood and they did that
yeah because i love nachos i'm a big
nacho guy i like it
and i love the mixture like i love
jalapenos i love black olives i love
a little sour cream on there yeah i love
the salsa
i love a shitload of cheese like it is
to me
the feel-good communal food yes yeah but
you're at a bar you're watching the game
you're with friends you got a couple
beers
i love nachos i'm just worried because i
don't want a plain chip
the chip to me is the vehicle for the
chili the sour cream the jalapeno the
black bean the cheese
guac whatever it is it's just a vehicle
for me yeah
and so if i get a chip without the same
amount as the middle guy
i'm bummed well this is a metaphor for
something bigger i mean you have like a
bernie sanders approach to your nachos
here
i mean we got jeff bezos over here it's
smothered in cheese and black olives
we got someone over here this is the
food stamps of nachos it's got nothing
going on
yes exactly exactly this nacho's on
medicaid and this guy owns uh
tahiti it's not fair but yeah bezos oh
no
bill gates yeah i just saw melinda on
bumble
all right no that was a tweet but yeah
yeah how about that huh yeah i had a
long i was hanging out with will still
vince he drove me home last night
and he was like it's so weird i thought
women liked money like why would she
break up with them i thought women liked
rich guys i'm like
they do until they get the money she's
got half of it
so she doesn't need him now well it's
funny when bezos is uh he got divorced
his wife i think became like the second
richest person that's hilarious that
you're that rich
that the person you divorce becomes the
next richest person
that's impressive yeah so true i know
and then
if you go on a date with them i hope she
pays
i mean let's be honest she got to get
that bill that's hilarious can you
imagine like going on a date with her
and you're just like you reach for your
wallet she doesn't even go for the purse
you're like all right [ __ ]
come on yeah i know you have microsoft
yeah that made me microsoft hey when
when god closes the door he opens the
windows
baby jokes i mean yeah she really that's
such a weird thing i mean
part of me is like if they can't make it
that is weird i agree
because you think like there's not a
better couples counselor you can afford
right they've got the best person if
they try and they've got the best home
they got the best cars they got the best
care
they got the best everything but that's
that's the problem when your home is too
big
i feel like that could hurt a marriage
it's almost like if your bed is too big
uh you're not cuddling interesting you
kind of got a distant thing going on
yeah that's true it's so easy to be in a
bad marriage
if you've got an 18 bedroom yeah
but then you're not sleeping on the
couch you're sleeping in the other
[ __ ]
sweet bed that's true but on the flip
side if you
you know me and my gal lived in this
tiny studio slash one bedroom and we
were at each other's throats because
it's too small
so they're kind of too small is way
worse there's it's way worse i think
there's a happy medium you're saying
because most people think the bigger the
better but
there's a middle ground yeah i think you
got something there yeah
i think reasonably big but also you want
to see the person
yeah i guess so tim burton
look this one up there a hair or matt
tim burton
is married to hell in a bottom carter
and they have two houses
okay well when they were together they
had fairly maybe their deal together she
omit you know what
i think she never got married no she was
with kenneth branagh
oh really yeah she's got an interesting
taste
both houses split they live next door to
each other and they each had their own
house
it says they they split okay they split
but at the time
see look they had a london home next
door to one another
and they were linked so they had like a
little tunnel connecting but they had
their own
houses pretty interesting interesting
i kind of like that i mean that's not
it's a kooky
i mean but you that's what you expect
yeah yeah and you expect johnny depp in
the third house to just walk out with
like 90 scarves and just be like hey
guys
right it's just a weird she she really
uh she's a great actress
great actor she was on the crown
recently that's right
that's right she's uh yeah i mean
obviously fight club
all of tim burton's movies she's in yeah
yeah yeah yeah she's got a
kooky vibe for sure it's cute when two
kooks get together
yeah you know like the weird kid in your
high school who's like the artsy goth
kid
starts hooking up with like the suicide
girl and you're like all right that's
good you guys are both weirdos and
cutters
and all that that is cute yeah it's kind
of like the jock and the prom queen you
know i like when
when those people meet you're rooting
for them yeah that's the whole basis for
us weekly
what do you mean well you're rooting for
these two actors to get together you're
like you know
two people if two people you like start
dating you're like oh good for them
it is fun and then you get to picture
them [ __ ] you're like wow
timberlake is [ __ ] cameron diaz
what's that like you know
that's exciting that's true that's an
old that's an old issue right there
i haven't been to the dentist in a while
humpty bogart and lauren mccall oh my
cheese mark you're really
wow liz taylor looks great uh when's the
last time you've been to the dentist by
the way it's been a long long time me
too
it's comedy well my parents had me on
this thing back when i was younger i'd
go twice a year and i hated it obviously
it's you know but now you look back and
like that was a good deal
that was a good deal i i hate it my dad
was like you're gonna miss this one day
when you're uh you know a broke [ __ ] or
whatever like ah shut up dad you don't
get me and then
cut to me at 37 i'm like [ __ ] i mean
there's like cleaning your dad
you know i just picture being like a
really bright guy just being like you
[ __ ] broke [ __ ]
yeah piece of [ __ ] he's putting on
aftershave
hitting my mom yeah no it's true i gotta
go and this house this is comedy in a
nutshell this is how sad this is
i'm going out to some gig somewhere i
think tacoma or seattle whatever and
no uh spokane and the guy my opener
andrew goes
there's a guy a dentist who does a
podcast and he gives you a cleaning
while he does a podcast you want to do
it i'm like
i'll do it because i get a free cleaning
where is it it's i think it's in spokane
i'm there i'm going there let me know
get them on
dennis dennis pod but that's how [ __ ]
up we are that i'm like
oh i'll do a podcast for the cleaning
holy [ __ ] yeah that's how bad it's
getting like
you did his podcast prostate exam yeah i
had to
get older yeah exactly you got a
colonoscopy yeah it was a web series
i had to do it yeah it's true
uh but i'll take it i'll take a cleaning
i mean i'm scared
do you floss i don't make a habit out of
it but i always think of hedberg's joke
or how hard is it to quit smoking it's
as hard
as to start flossing i think about that
all the time great joke but i uh
i did last night but i almost i don't
always do it it's like man
that's how you know you got a drinking
problem like like you know you
you've never flossed because you're just
drunk you're like ah
you're drunk your drunks barely brushed
their teeth before bed like
face first down yeah i try to i try to
i'm going to try to my mom says it's me
all the time make sure to floss it's
such a mom thing to say
yeah floss and take your vitamins my
mom's hilarious with the vitamins
because she'll tell me vitamins taken
she's like what are you taking i tell
her oh i'm taking uh genius mushrooms
also the pills i take uh valerian to go
to bed my mom's like
what are these i'm like you tell me to
take fish oil yeah
what do you think yours are [ __ ]
proven in fact
i think fish oil is good fish oil is
good it's good for the joints valerian
is good i think for your
uh it calms you before bed it's good
like i think magnesium is good before
bed
yeah i've heard that but i mean uh it's
like
zinc is good yeah i feel like zinc is
like the number one
i feel like zinc just keeps you from
getting really sick yeah zinc is big
i should be taking all these but then
some people like vitamins aren't real
yeah you know but then they're like
professional wrestling and scientology
is
not the holocaust but yeah oh that's
interesting wait hold on i had some what
were we talking about four vitamins uh
harry [ __ ] oh we're all about
carter now after that people are getting
furious at us right now
oh [ __ ] sorry matt ah he's jerking off
he's uh he's checked up oh damn it i had
something before vitamins
ah it's gone all right dentist
dentist oh flossing nice
we got it back teamwork with the booze
mind you and we got it for the sober
people
uh you know that flossing stick now that
they have
yeah that little like claw thing some
say it's not good for you
oh really yeah interesting well i like
those things better
i love that thing because this thing
with the you know the string and you're
getting this [ __ ] on your fingers i hate
it
but the claw thing to me stuff like that
gives me hope and humanity
because it's like we had this string for
500 years
whatever the hell floss has lasted all
of a sudden there were
flossing 500 years ago i assume people
are getting in there with like a
you know maybe a toothpick sort of thing
a twig or a toothpick or yeah something
a
root 1815 okay so 100
something 200 years we'll say yeah and
change hilarious are using twigs you're
like yeah you just got an even worse
disease
from the twig oh wow invented new
orleans i never knew that
put that in your cap there nola but
the claw thing is such a great
improvement on floss and that just came
out what
15 years ago whatever it is i love that
kind of [ __ ] because it you think we
have it all hammered down this is how
it's supposed to be and then we come out
with something better
and to me that is a great sign about
about humans that's a good point you
know what i like about the claw too you
could flip it around
and poke things first i mean it's kind
of got the double weapon there double
thing yeah
the claw's genius and i'm trying to
think of other things like that you know
that we keep upgrading over time the
razor maybe
yeah feel like the razor's made like
it's funny we
offer all the upgrades we've made in the
razor we always go back to the single
blade
yeah this one's got five blades you're
like is that not too much
right right i'm five trying to kill
myself here folks and that razor you
can't cut
so i got a a good wreck for you and this
isn't my goal for the week it's not my
wreck for the week
okay but just to wreck in general for
shaving i think it's called ten skin
and it's if you get razor bumps i get
razors all the time skin
pour a little there on you you're good
interesting ten skin isn't a blue bottle
ten skin sedan smith turned me onto it
okay great
great i love it uh good because i kind
of like razor burn because it hides the
herpes
no i'm just kidding uh i guess you don't
have herpes though then it just looks
like you have herpes
yeah good point good point um oh we can
let's give our wreck because i feel like
we're where we're going
we're going down the barrel here uh i
got a weird one today
love a weird wreck okay i'm gonna shout
out now
i'm giving a restaurant but it's a chain
so i think it's nationwide i love it
restaurants are hurting this is a great
idea well i don't know if this one's
hurting because it is a you know
probably a multi-million dollar whatever
but
the restaurant cava i love cava
is that today so they have the hummus in
the middle eastern type they got all
that
and it's like it's like chipotle style
where exactly you go down the line you
go i want that i want the base i want
the
quinoa i want the cauliflower i want the
meatballs i want the stewed chicken
my favorite is the pickled the pickled
onions and the pickles oh yeah and
that's all free at the end you get the
cilantro and the pickled onions and the
cabbage and the
the olive mix or whatever the hell it is
get some cabba it's a little expensive
but maybe that's in new york it's like
you end up
it's great you're gonna spend like 13
bucks but it is so
filling you're full after you're
satisfied your breath is horrible but
i love cava shout out to cava
yeah it's great there used to be a place
kind of like it in the uh
in the east village when i was a young
comic and trying to get a cheap meal it
was
they give you a huge pita and you've got
unlimited stuff in there
so i would literally keep getting the
jam [ __ ] in there so i get the
fattest meal for like five bucks it was
great i remember that it did not last
long because of people like me probably
but uh yeah coff is great i'm i'm a fan
all right
yeah it was work because people get
weird about chains and [ __ ] but i
i don't want to say some random new york
restaurant because it would be like
cavaz everything they've got the like
jalapeno hummus they've got that it's
great i love middle eastern food
and uh and it's a nice mix because
chains tend to be mcdonald's or wendy's
e
or whatever or just salad or chopped or
whatever but this is like
interesting weird different kind of
tastes and foods and
spices you ever sometimes i was trying
to be healthy and all like let me order
chopped i'm lazy and like i'm not going
to spend 26
in a salad that's crazy it's insane it's
a it's a smart business move because
you're just
thinking with your stomach and you just
go down the line you're like i'll have
salmon
yeah i'll have ham i'll have egg and
then before you know it it's 19.99
i love the choose your own adventure
style of eden though i love the picking
and cheese
yeah some people are very against it in
the times of covid because you know
but i'm like they're wearing a mask well
i think we're fine yeah that's another
great innovation i love when things get
innovative like
sushi was like a big deal when i was
getting sushi you had to go to a
restaurant the guy would bow
and everything was like pristine you
know and it was just sacrifices
like this is yeah there was like a weird
little waterfall in the side and you
know
some guy had a samurai sword and now
it's like
he got a sushi little little plastic
thing at the uh grocery store and it's
solid
true sushi 90s sushi just plain my heart
will go on with a pan flute
yeah exactly it's great there was some
weird kid
meditating on a bamboo rug you know it
was so it was so intense and now sushi
is like ah sushi yeah i see you now get
a [ __ ] rite aid
yeah yeah exactly it's great americans
ruin everything
i know we make everything quick cheap
and easy which
richard jenny used to have a great bit
about how the how the french of the
croissant and we in america would go hey
take your chrysanthemum with your fat
bastard
underrated comedian incredible check out
richard jenny platypus man if you
haven't
and stephen pile of me is great one of
the funniest yeah so funny
so funny my wreck this is gonna sound
crazy
i had never seen this movie before it is
an american classic
and i am ashamed of but sometimes
there's so many classics we have so many
great american movies that
some are going to slip through the
cracks oh this is one of them jaws
oh amazing 1975 the first
summer blockbuster mind you incredible
incredible
and i've seen scenes of it but i'd never
seen it start to finish and i was so
ashamed
i was like let me just take a night i
was embarrassed
that i've never seen it i'll tell you
another thing post covet it plays so
interestingly and like
you know the politician who like shut
down the beach
man this makes this is so relevant now
yes interesting
good call you won't sit down at the
beach even though it's dangerous and
you're like [ __ ] this is like
tourist season think about all the
cities that are hurting
tourist-wise it's tough yeah and also
it's a message that people are the same
you know we think we're all high and
mighty and
and new age but we're all everything's
just repeating itself
people are all [ __ ] up it's also weird
to watch that movie and be like man i'd
kill for just to be a shark
i know right i can just stay out of the
water and be fine that's it
it's still tour no worries yeah
yeah by the way sharks kill less people
than cows but we just
sharks are kind of like the black people
of of the sea
everybody's like scared of them but
they're not even killing that many
people
all right dangerous road we're taking
yeah sorry
that's defending you know it's sexier if
it's this if it's like a racial thing
but
it's actually okay uh
jaws so good and that's a young
spielberg and the shark had so there's
all these
books and stories about jaws like the
shark barely worked that's why they had
to use it so little because it was this
big machine that was shitty
and uh that's why they show it less but
that worked
showing it less made it more more
enticing and more
imagination kicked in you know fear is
better when it's in your mind
that's that's a great point special
effects won't always age well
yeah but psychological stuff it [ __ ]
with you i mean that's why psycho is so
great
that's why i like certain classics you
wanna make the shining
yeah and also a lot of foreplay you know
just like oh god here it go no that
wasn't it oh
no that wasn't and then the big
crescendo at the end i mean
who's the actor the main guy in that
with the glasses roy scheider
he's great he's great yeah french
connection yes
great great new york movie have you ever
seen the
i think the greatest car chase scene
maybe in movie history
french connection the gene hackman chase
scene where they're going subway to
subway i'm like oh my god
that one yeah that was insane that was
like a perfectly orchestrated
uh the whole thing everything was
perfect timing-wise and
and just gritty then we've gotten rid of
the grit
in movies look at that i mean remember
that scene where
like the there's a guy trying to rape a
lady and he stops it
and yeah oh my god he goes to the
basketball court to shake down the black
guy i mean just
look at this this is unbelievable this
is like 1971 i want to say
yeah and they're chasing this is on the
subway in new york i mean this is great
stuff this is thrilling uh before rules
and regulations
i mean it's like the pace of the scene
uh
it's really crazy yeah gene hackman is
one of the coolest actors ever
like yeah really just you know fun fact
about gene hackman he was
cast as mr robinson in the graduate
what mike nicholls i could see that yeah
he would but he was too young
so there was a day where dustin
hoffman's like man because mike nichols
[ __ ] with dustin hoffman the whole
time and that's absolutely right
and dustin hoffman said i'm doing a
horrible job i can't i don't know why
you hate me i'm doing horribly it was
like this big break and i'm doing
horribly and
and gene hackman's like nah they're
gonna fire me and he's like what are you
talking about you're amazing he's like
yeah he's like nah i got a feeling
later that day he got fired and it was
because my nickel is like you he's too
young no one's gonna buy him he's like
eight years older than
yeah and dustin hoffman it makes sense
that's so funny that these actors were
nervous you know we see them as such
legends and they're like i'm out they
hate me
yeah but can't you picture young like
picture not famous dustin hoffman he's
like five foot
five like i don't think he's just like
i'm the [ __ ]
yeah he was like [ __ ] yeah no i i get it
it makes sense but
he i just rewatched that too he killed
it and uh
mrs robinson apparently in the movie is
like 38
and she's like this old lady so funny
yeah and bancroft was hot in that movie
oh so hot so sexy great
great one of the great i mean talk about
great american movies of all time like
yeah the graduates
[ __ ] incredible and they were trying
to they were trying to sell it as like a
sex comedy in the 60s because the studio
had no
confidence in it oh damn best picture of
the year i think
i think i think i won best picture did
it yeah i think it was 68 academy awards
harry check it out uh
it definitely was nominated i never won
yeah
uh great movie though it's it's uh it's
got the uh truffaut influence it's very
uh french new wave vibe yeah i think
that was one of the first times it came
over here and
hit the mainstream did it win best oscar
harry
best director what won that year
68 i think because i remember i
seriously just [ __ ] read a book about
this and i don't remember
what one mike nichols had a run he's fun
he's a fun story because he has a rare
disease
and he lost all his hair when he was
like 16. married to diane sawyer
what yeah from louisville kentucky
but uh yes his whole life is a piece
he's wearing a piece
no [ __ ] and it's a great hairpiece
in the here great movie
and turned into a tv show steiger won
best actor that year and couldn't get a
job afterwards
oh wow is that right yeah show biz man
if we're in the heat of the night wow
showbiz sucks
showbiz [ __ ] sucks and here's another
reason showbiz sucks that year
in the heat of the night and um what's
the other one
with sydney partier guess who's coming
to dinner both nominated such different
racial stories
oh yeah like so true true because coming
to dinner is like the hollywood eyes
[ __ ] like right we're good people
but you're really 12 years behind at
best
right and then in the heath of nights it
kind of like it's still got problems but
it's a pretty gritty mississippi cop
movie oh yeah
oh yeah that is a gritty dark [ __ ] up
twisted movie but great check it out
uh we should do a bit oh we should do a
bit i feel like yeah we ran off on uh
movies to
on this app we run all over the place
buddy that's that's the joy of this pod
i never did peeves ooh all right give me
a peeve and i'll give you
i got two peas but i'll go i'll pick one
all right
now this is a maybe a part of a bigger
thing but i i
i think it's a bad sign i was hanging
out with a guy last weekend
do you know the guy who hates anyone
who's better than him
you know like they go oh this guy's uh
every comedian of all time
well it's okay to be like oh i gotta
work on that or he's better than me at
that i suck but i hate the uh
oh he's got that [ __ ] him yeah like oh
this guy's killing it oh he's go
[ __ ] that guy i'm like well what do you
mean [ __ ] that guy he just found a way
to do great
and you're hating on him already it's
like i get it's kind of a half joke but
you're like oh that guy's six two oh
he's six two i'm five nine [ __ ] that guy
like
shut up he didn't choose me six two how
about you make some of your life instead
of just
hating everybody that's doing better
than you i don't love the the go
to hate it's a hard guy to be around it
is
it is we're done like yes and that's a
yes no
yeah like maybe i'm a minority here but
i don't understand the elon musk on snl
like
we act like this is the first unfunny
guy to host snl we've had
trump we've had well you know what i
think and like i don't personally give a
[ __ ] i don't
watch it either but i think the hate
with him is like how billionaires have
just become
ultra wealthy uh during this pandemic
and most people have lost a shitload of
money so i think
the the hate is coming from a reasonable
place where it's kind of like
you're rewarding this guy like uh i
think
i mean how would you feel bezos hosted
you know i think it's i think it's
interesting i think it's interesting too
but like you got to understand the hate
too
i guess for me it's like i think it's a
genius ratings i think it is too because
all these people are bubbling up so like
well now i'll watch i'm not really
watching snl
but i'll watch because of this yeah i
mean i'm probably still not going to
watch i mean we work on saturdays and i
just i don't really care that i don't
give a youtube i mean yeah
i mean i'm curious to see a monologue i
mean
i get the hate i just don't really i
personally am just like sometimes those
make for interesting episodes like back
in the day rudy giuliani hosted snl and
i thought it was really funny yeah there
you go sometimes it's fun to have a fish
out of water
moment in there you know this guy's a
politician or a soccer player or
something or
forbes hosted one like what is this but
it's kind of
it mixes it up people like to kind of
they add and look i guess snl does have
cultural relevance and
especially political relevance and they
got really mad when trump hosted
yeah my issue is only when they when
people try to play both sides of it like
i was
you know just as a spectator i was like
oh you're gonna bash trump every week
but
you had him host your show right right
the hypocrisy of it is like a little
like all right but i also think like you
know
it is an entertainment show yeah exactly
it is there
to get ratings yes it is hard to get i
mean this is how bad snl
has to get ratings and it's like not i
mean they have an incredibly talented
cast
and they still get like jim carrey to
come in and do a character right
you're not telling me that someone on
the cast can't do [ __ ] biden better
than jim carrey
yeah get carvy back in there dana
carvey's joe biden
kills is incredible and it's kind of a
throwback like hey these older guys
are pros don't forget about them these
guys killed in their
in their prime and still killed this day
and there's like a real
youthful vibe on snl which i get that's
always how it's been
not for prime time players but let's not
sleep on these uh these geezers
cause they're they're killers i'm such a
big dana carvey fan
love dana carter he was in this movie
when was a kid called opportunity knox
and it's like
it's not a good movie but i love it is
that the one where he's in an la
apartment with a hot lady
yeah yeah he's a he's a con man the
premise is ridiculous he's a con man
and he and his friend are robbing a
house and it's a really fancy house
yeah and they get a voicemail ah i guess
i'm not gonna get to meet you and get
the house sit for two weeks and take
like a look at each other like
party and they take over the house and
he's
he's a con man and robert loggia is like
a guy he ends up like climbing the
ladder at robert loggia's company
and he's like i like you there's
something in here and
but like dude i think it [ __ ] up his
film career a little bit because he got
paid stupid money for it oh yeah and it
just bombed but
i watched it i was like man dana carvey
is so [ __ ] charismatic
oh he's grumpy he's a talent he's a
beast
he's great i mean he did a movie about
where he was like turtle turtle what was
that movie where
oh master in disguise yeah it's a
horrible movie it's a piece of
flaming pile of dog [ __ ] but he's great
in it yeah he's amazing i mean
wayne's world one and two wayne's world
the church lady i mean so
even his stand-up special was good
chopping broccoli yeah the ross perot
can i finish can i finish all that was
great he did like every president he did
every president bush is incredible
bush is great he was great yeah big fan
of the carve
one of the great he's he's probably my
fave five snl guys ever i think
oh really he's got to be it makes sense
it makes sense
phil hardman too for sure all right what
do you got on uh p
he's all right um [ __ ] i wrote one down
let me see
but the snl thing with musk it's like i
get it but it's just weird
when the cast member was like i'm not
going on i'm protesting like
this is what what it is protesting it's
kind of like
all right well you're not gonna last you
know like choose your profuse
battles but also uh are you that
bothered but he's also
you do this to get ratings i mean that's
the point and and he's
people are talking about it mission
accomplished there you go
um okay this is one it's listen to pee
if it's kind of funny to me but it's
it's still a peeve i'm like i'm like an
elevator and just [ __ ] there's a
white guy just like rapping loudly
she's like rapping to his music with his
headphones in i hate it already
and i wanted to just turn and be like
hey excuse me uh
i work for a record company you've got
the goods
that's why you're doing this right
because you want people to notice you're
an amazing [ __ ] right
exactly it's ridiculous is he
pronouncing like hey guys i'm gonna do a
wrap
here's some here's my hat for some money
oh god this guy's this guy's all out to
lunch i hate this guy yeah
he's just rapping comedy special after
lunch it's a good way to work here
yeah it is that's the whole point is
that i'm out to lunch but yeah
that's that's horrific he's rapping
loudly i hate this guy
i don't like people i i did a peeve on
this last week where it's like
i don't like people taking over common
space
yes it's always been a peeve of mine
have some respect for everybody
there's something about it then again i
choose to live in new york city
so it's a pretty [ __ ] dumb peeve to
have but these aren't things that i
can't take these are peeves they're
peeves yeah you sit there and you deal
with it but
my question is let's say you started
rapping like there's that great curb
moment where a guy's on a bluetooth at a
restaurant just alone
and so larry starts going and then i did
this and he's talking to himself and the
guy's like what are you doing he's like
what are you doing what's there he's
like i'm talking to somebody he's like
what's the difference
you can't see who i'm talking to
whatever and that's how i feel like you
should start rapping in front of this
guy and see how he likes it fake rap
battles yeah fake rap battle
give him a taste of what's what and then
go a hippie to the hop to the hippie dog
i'm gonna hip it to the hop what subway
stop are you going two
two you i got nothing
you never see people they always
blasting rap on the subway you never see
someone like hold up a speaker it's just
like james taylor or some [ __ ]
that's true james taylor fans are quiet
[Laughter]
yeah they don't really make noise but
yeah rapping out loud on the subway it
it takes a little balls and
vulnerability to go hey folks if you
like my rap give me a buck or whatever
but to just do it
outright like that he was just singing
along to the music with his headphones
no if it was his own i'd have a little
more responsibility yeah yeah that's
what i thought he was doing his own [ __ ]
i saw a guy on the subway once come on
and started reading poetry and i'm like
man you've got some balls
yeah poetry's got you gotta have balls
nobody likes poetry nobody
nobody's going to a poetry slam or a you
know stand-up poetry or a poetry club
it's tough it is it is yeah i mean that
save that [ __ ] for your girlfriend or a
love letter
and you better be doing it during a
breakup you do it to win her back don't
break it out casually
yes oh it was it his or was it it was
his
oh man that's tough yeah poor guy
what give me a bet all right i got two
ideas so uh
one i'll just do one cause we're running
low here but i got this whole bit about
how
men are horny and this is raw i got i
don't know where to go with it so
bear with me men are horny and bear
in the setup here yeah yeah men are
horny and we
it ruins us you know because women like
hey it sucks i'm a woman i get pregnant
i have to take time off i have to raise
a kid i might not be able to go far in
my career
because i get pregnant i'm like i get it
but men get horny
and look how many careers that's ruined
it's like epstein
and kobe and cosby
if we didn't get horny imagine the the
amount we would flourish
we have to deal with our horniness i
wouldn't give examples because you're
given examples of rapists
ah i think that immediately is like a
good point i did ruin kobe's career he
came back from it
he did come back yeah something else
ruined his career helicopter
yeah yeah uh then
but it's a definitely a hindrance yeah
maybe pregnant is the wrong angle
because that's like no i think that's
great
it's both biological i like it that's
the well this is biological
so is me being horny that's very marked
voice i also think you know
i wouldn't even give examples look how
many careers this is ruined
you know uh i was horny it's tough that
the tough thing is you have to make that
no one's like i want to ruin my career
no yeah it's like i want
yeah but you get no you get no sympathy
for horny
yeah but it is a biological thing like
i'm
your your horniness it's i get it this
is dicey waters because it's like sexual
harassment suits all the time and all
that no but that's that's you at your
best i think dicey waters i mean
yeah i'm not saying it's good i'm just
saying it is a factor that we should
we don't really um include it in the
debate men will
jack off before date to act like humans
on the date
there you go that's a great example it's
so true
yeah and then i feel like the ending of
the bit could be like well i get
pregnant i'm like how do you think you
got pregnant i was horned
that's the big i already got the ending
but i need the middle
the gooey middle nougat so i think
that's something like
it just i have a line in the beginning
where i'm like
men are horny other women and women go
no and i go ladies you've never gone to
a family or union go
i would do it you know and that kills so
like that kind of shows like what we're
willing to do
because of our horniness men are [ __ ]
animals
we're [ __ ] relatives because we're
that's how bad it is
i'll tell you what ruins a career is
[ __ ] a family member
yeah look at woody allen right exactly
look at woody allen exactly perfect
example but again
he's like a bad guy it's tough i think
you have to make it
like i think you have to say just like
generic me too because that way
the mind doesn't go straight to
hopefully all right maybe it does still
i it's tough
that's why it's tough because no one has
you because you don't want to sound like
you're defending
exactly a rapist you want to sound like
you're
defending the horniness yeah yeah
but look how much i'm horny as hell look
how much i get done
yeah i do two podcasts i do the road i
do four shows a night how many times i
jacked off today
i know but you get no sympathy it's kind
of i have another bit about sex workers
i'm like i've been supporting them for
years
and everybody's like oh that's that
doesn't count i'm like well you support
this group in that group
i've been paying her this this girl's
rent you know like
why just because i'm getting blown
doesn't mean i'm not a hero
all right maybe there's nothing there
but i'm working on it
i think sex worker is becoming more and
more accepted it is i think it's like
becoming more legal and more accepted
that people still i remember i uh i saw
a comic once on stage say he paid for
sex and it wasn't even true it was like
a mysteric
but he said that and it got like a big
arm yeah yeah people
from women too by the way i bet also no
one would even believe that like you're
a good looking guy i think you know yeah
i've never actually gotten a prostitute
but i'd like the idea that
like you're all of a sudden it's like a
weird gray area of
are you a good guy or not but i'm like
i've been helping this [ __ ] out
but you're still so maybe don't make it
about you so if i were to do this i
think maybe it's a better observational
joke because it's not true i think maybe
you're losing people
like i don't think that's true yeah
maybe you're right maybe you're right
all right
i'll just make it about a general the
idea of it i think yeah i think the
other bit too it's like it's a great i
love the horny versus pregnant thing i
think
okay that's great i mean they're both
things
maybe go they're both things that ruin
careers yeah
true uh difference is
a women can come back they can come back
from being pregnant
yeah and you get paid to be gone no guy
gets paid to leave because he was horny
that's good
maybe bill o'reilly
[Laughter]
i think he got a nice settlement yeah
yeah but but nick griffin has that great
bit about like i called it horny to work
so i'm trying to
which is such a killer face check that
out if you haven't seen it i think it's
on letterman
or color he's one of the best but yeah i
don't want to delve into that that whole
pond but
uh yeah i think i think that's something
there all right and i just want to keep
it away from like
abusive men or or whatever for sure
all right what do you got so this is a
weird one this is like a riff the other
night and a hit and i think this could
be a bit
someone was telling me in the crowd that
she had a pet tarantula
i said man you know you got a shitty pet
when the second of gets out of the cage
you think
i guess i got to kill it that's funny
you know what i mean like you have a you
have a guinea pig it gets out of the
cage you're like oh look at it you're a
tarantula gets out you're like put your
[ __ ] mouth on the curb
you know yes so true i feel
similarly and i don't know if i'm i'm
going off off the rails here but
with uh you know some people i see with
dogs with muzzles i'm like
this is your pet you have to put a
muzzle on it you know like just to hang
out with it just to go to the parking to
put a muzzle on what's the point yeah
why don't you adopt hannibal lecter for
[ __ ] sake exactly you're hanging out
with a murderer or a you know
a violent being so yeah uh
yeah right when it gets out you gotta
kill it it's the same with people with
snakes
this thing gets out you're done it's
such a weird status thing where people
have like a pet tiger remember mike
tyson
and you're just like i understand this
makes you feel powerful
but guess what won't make you feel
powerful if that thing gets out of its
cage
yeah you're gonna feel like kind of a
[ __ ] yeah
i wonder if there's an analogy of like
you know those people who have
boyfriends they're like he's great at
home but i can't take him anywhere
it's the same with that like he's great
in the in the
aquarium thing but you can't let it out
yeah it's not a great pet you want to be
able to you literally can't do the thing
that it's named after which is pet it
it's a pet
you can't pet it it's a stay away yeah
i'm getting two 80s but uh yeah
with these rotary phones i got a cord on
it
uh hmm can't even let it out of the
box it's kept in yeah it's too violent
that's something they're just you don't
want a scary pet like why would you get
a hairy pet your pet shouldn't want to
kill you yeah
that's the whole the whole point of a
pet is love and companionship
and you know cuddling and all that and
you can't even do that
so you're just really keep you're just
enjoying having a murderer in your home
you're like look at this murderer i got
it in my house that's the fun part yeah
i should answer
i want i want to see you i want to see
what your boyfriend's like yeah exactly
yeah can't take him anywhere every time
uh
i let him out he kills somebody hmm
there's something here i'll crack this
there is something first part head
there's something there oh yeah yeah
yeah when i did as a referee killed i
think i think it could work and i did it
the next night and it hit but it needs a
little more i think
yeah the animal animals are uh
it's weird the different types of
animals you know
ferret is weird honestly unless you have
a dog or cat it's a little weird
i agree even goldfish is a little weird
yeah you want a pet that like
it's gonna die that soon don't get me
started on a parrot
this thing's got to sit in a cage any
bird any bird they can't fly that's
their whole purpose in life
just birds are weird i know parrots are
like [ __ ] it's like having an alexa
they're listening true
it's an alexa that doesn't know anything
it can talk but
you're like hey you can't have to parrot
the weather it goes [ __ ] you
or whatever yeah at least alex has
information
i bet the mafia doesn't have paris you
don't want a bird
it was him yeah that's that's funny
it could be some parrot that parrot
alexa thing i like maybe
but the tarantula is interesting why
would you want a pet that'll kill you
have you i've never seen a tarantula
that i liked no i've never seen like
positive tarantula pr even in a movie
when has ever been like oh cool
tarantula yeah there's no pixar about a
friendly tarantula yeah they did
pixar was able to pull off a friendly
rat they couldn't do a friendly
tarantula
good point yeah even at home alone the
tarantula got out and it bit one of the
bad guys
that was the high end i guess that's
good though you do want to bite a bad
guy i guess
but even then you're kind of rooting for
the bad guys right yeah because you
relate to them all right it's the
scariest
thing you guys are home invaders and
you're like [ __ ] that bug yeah
yeah the tarantula that's true i don't
get any of those pets the snake
tarantula anything that's vicious dog or
cat
really and if i guess guinea pigs are
kind of cute too they're kind of funny
sure sure but like dog cat guinea pig
and
and maybe if you're like i'd be a
hamster like maybe a hamster i get yeah
yeah but i mean not my favorite but no i
i get it
i'm with you dog a cat of my yeah
agreed so yeah i'm with you on the
tarantula i'm just trying to find the
turn
trying to find the i got enough to play
with here this is it's just terrific
i think i got a few angles here to play
with it's got legs
all right eight of them okay we'll plug
some dates where are you gonna be
oh yeah i'm all over the road here
houston albany syracuse buffalo
uh portland all these clubs i i you know
what's
a bummer uh is uh these clubs they don't
put the link up for a while so i get all
these tweets like when's the link going
up i'm like i don't know you gotta fight
them man
you gotta fight on virginia beach uh all
kinds of good stuff
toledo oh that could be weird city of
glass
philly the glass manufacturing city
dayton arlington
brea in l.a uh uh is that right
west palm beach oh you got some good
improv coming up yeah i got a lot of
those same rooms coming up i got salt
lake this month
i got arlington virginia this month i'm
bringing anthony devito to
salt lake i'm bringing to vitor to
arlington gary veda our boy oh
i got albany i got tampa i got raleigh
i got a ton of [ __ ] oh good club uh yeah
all good clubs
i'm i'm so pumped at my tour schedule
and uh
go to samurai.com shows i'm i'm going
portland too i'm doing
kentucky all over the [ __ ] map so
lexington
yeah that's a fun road oh one of the
all-time classic clubs i saw your name
on on the wall yeah comedy off broadway
classic classical bringing
hershberg to that one oh nice i got dina
hashem with me in uh
in tampa bringing great comics on the
road with me so you're getting a great
show
hell yeah oh orlando too so yeah boston
too
there you go let's [ __ ] go we're
coming we're coming for you baby
we're back on the road on the road again
so yeah tell a friend spread the word
send your peeves we might be drunk pod
at gmail
drink wrecks somebody sent me a drink
right he's like you're gonna love this
it's gin and ice i was like get the hell
out of here
[ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah i don't know if he
was being funny or what but uh i gotta
gotta be funny then we got yeah go
follow our instagram page we're
promoting a lot of comics we like on
there we got clips coming
we we're we're recording this at gotham
studios in new york city they're doing
such a great job here on uh
38th street we love them yeah i love the
setup uh
we got harry producing we got matt in
the booth
we're we're rocking we're rolling i feel
good about this
uh we'll keep we'll keep boozing i like
this you pick one round i pick the next
round four episodes is fun
love it yeah just you i feel weird i had
to carry a bunch of liquor in my
backpack all day
like what am i 16. i know exactly give
me uh give me some
some taco and a gatorade bottle and
we'll go to a concert
limp biscuits in town all right thanks
folks
we'll see you next week subscribe to the
patreon uh patreon.com we might be drunk
pod
we'll read your wrecks your jokes your
peeves drinks all that [ __ ]
can't wait to get at it and uh see you
soon